اذا ذكر الطعام الحار
ذكرت الهند
هنا قائمه طويله من اصناف واشكال الطعام
المرتبطه ارتباطا وثيقا بالتوابل
والبهارات متعدده الالوان والروائح المطبخ
الهندي الشديد التنوع يتاثر بالمناخ او
بقرب المدن من المحيط او الصحراء كما تؤثر
الخلفيات الثقافيه المتنوعه بشكل كبير في
انواع الطعام التي يتناولها السكان
والاطعواق الشوارع نجد كل ما نحتاجه من
بهارات وخضروات هذه هي الاطعمه التي
نستخدمها كل يوم
استخدام التوابل هو العامل المشترك لجميع
تقاليد الطهي في الهند سواء كانت نباتيه
ام لا في اللحوم او الاسماك او الخضروات
التوابل هي التي تصنع تناغم كل هذه
الاطباق
ما اعدته هنا هو طبق من ولايه راجستان نحن
ناكل هذا في كل بيت هنا لدينا العدس
ولدينا البطاطا والقرنبيط وصلصه الريتات
وهنا صلصه من اللبن والقليل من الخبز وبعض
الارز ونوع من الفطائر المقرمشه يوجد منها
ما هو مالح وما هو حلم
ربما لا يخلو منزل هندي من طبق المساله
الشهير وهو خليط من التوابل المختلفه الذي
يستخدمه الهنود في تجهيز معظم الوجبات
تقريبا
روائح المطبخ الهندي تتجلى في اكشاك
الطعام المتوفره بكثره في شوارع وازقه
الهند في كل شارع انواع مختلفه من الوجبات
التقليديه سريعه التحضير واحده من اشهر
هذه الوجبات تدعى كاتشوري
عباره عن كعكه محجوبه تحظى بشعبيه كبيره
في وجبه الافطار الهنديه لكن يمكن تناولها
كوجبه خفيفه ويمكنك تناولها طوال اليوم
بعض اكشاك الشارع تحولت بمرور الزمن الى
مؤسسات حقيقيه ضعافيتها في مدن باكملها
وتوافد عليها الالاف منذ عشرات السنين
منها محل بان كيشان جولاني
العجه منذ 36 عاما كل يوم ابدا في الصباح
من الساعه العاشره صباحا حتى الساعه
العاشره مساء العجه المفضله للجميع هنا هي
عجه الماسانه المكونه من البصل الفلفل
الاخضر الكزبره الزنجبيل القليل من
الطماطم بيضتين تخلطها معا وها هي قد
اصبحت جاهزه
اكشاك الطعام الصغيره في شوارع الهند
مهدده بالاختفاء لعده اسباب اقتصاديه وان
حدث واختفت يوما ما فانها ستاخذ معها ارثا
كاملا من سحر المطبخ الهندي